are hearing from three Nashville police
officers who risked their lives to stop
last week's deadly school shooting they
were first on the scene as the shooter
targeted children and adults inside the
Covenant School killing six people in
all before the officers were able to
kill the attacker see the officials say
the men prevented a much greater loss of
life Mark Strassman has their first
public comments on what happened and we
warn you that some of this video is
disturb me
it's tough but our Department's done a
phenomenal job our support doesn't just
go towards officers it goes to the
family three Nashville officers praised
for stopping last week's school shooting
are now talking for the first time about
those horrifying moments once we started
hearing the first shots that's when
everything kind of kicked into overdrive
for us detective Michael Collazo was one
of the first to enter the Covenant
School along with Detective Sergeant
Jeff Mathis and Officer Rick Engelbert
Metro Police not knowing what I was
walking into I
went through that door with purpose kept
walking towards the gun to sound a
gunfire I couldn't get to it fast enough
I just looked for uh the nearest
staircase I could find because I could
tell it was above my head body camera
footage show the officers and some of
them had never worked together before
that moment methodically moving about
the Halls before taking down 28 year old
shooter Audrey Hale
they was so in tune to trying to get in
and take this threat down that they
didn't think about their own safety they
just wanted to save kids
police say Hale fired 152 rounds the
shooter killed three nine-year-olds and
three staff members yesterday police
revealed they entered 47 items into
evidence after executing a search
warrant at the shooter's home they also
found a suicide note and journals
indicating the massacre had been planned
for months and discovered more weapons
and ammunition while many are praising
the officers they quickly turned the
focus back to the victims and their
grieving families and credited any
heroic actions to their training I took
an oath to Serve and Protect this
community
my family sometimes comes second it has
to
police have yet to release a motive in
the shooting but what happened here
brought thousands of gun control
Advocates to protest at Tennessee's
state capitol building the Republican
majority's response delay action on
legislation that would expand gun rights
here to next year
John
mark thank you